invisibility is an out of this world
supernatural feature
that we usually associate with spirits
and ghosts
intangibility is even more mind-boggling
and hair-raising
just imagine the uneasy feeling of
running your hand right through the
ghost
that's why it's not at all surprising
that invisibility and intangibility
are what makes skeptics out of most
people who come across the rope model of
light and gravity
for the first time why can't we see or
touch the ropes that mediate
electromagnetic
phenomena how is it that countless ropes
serving as physical go-betweens during
gravity avoid getting tangled with each
other
we could answer simply that perhaps in
her infinite wisdom and compassion
mother nature knitted her threads
invisible and intangible
so that we wouldn't trip over them
or get tied up in knots however
there's a more mundane explanation it
has to do with a persistent
experience that we intuitively learned
to take for granted
since childhood we casually think of an
object as that which we can see or touch
because we use our visual and tactile
senses every second of the day
and yet although areas made of atoms no
differently than a rock or a tree
we can't see the air a fact that puzzled
the ancient greeks so much
they glorified as one of the fundamental
elements
so we don't think of air as an object in
our ordinary speech
despite that it is made of atoms
building blocks we normally associate
with more
rigid things
in principle if we cannot see individual
atoms much less can we expect to see the
electromagnetic ropes that interconnect
them
and are several orders thinner we learn
from this that it is not seeing
or touching that defines an object not
all objects enjoy these attributes
the only universal property objects have
is shape
in a universe consisting of a single
cube made of a single piece
we have shape and form but there is as
yet neither touch
nor c nor motion of any kind which in
all cases would require a second
object the lonely cube also lacks color
as well as mass and it is not comprised
of physical or temporal parts
only those words in the dictionary which
allude to shape or form
qualify as objects for the purposes of
physics
here again many would argue that gases
such as air and liquids such as water
don't have shape and therefore do not
qualify as objects under this definition
despite that they're comprised of atoms
actually
anything made of atoms does indeed have
shape
if an astronaut releases water in outer
space that blob has
shape although an irregular
indescribable one
similarly the oxygen and other molecules
that comprise the air that encapsulates
our planet
collectively take on the form of a shell
both air and water curve around our
globe
because each atom that comprises these
bodies is bound to all others that
comprise the earth
the electromagnetic ropes don't get
tangled because in their vanishingly
thin world
they lack the macro world property of
touch that we experience
every moment of our lives it is the
misconceived notion of the strategic
word object
and the unwarranted expectation of
discovering mother nature's secret
agents through experiments
that has prevented theorists from
zeroing in on the rope model of light
and gravity but the fact that we can see
molecules and what they build in the
macro world
gives us hope to understand how mother
nature produces tangibility
the key is aggregation during the
phenomenon we know is magnetism
countless threads bunch up to form a
nascent wall that pushes and pulls on
its counterparts
despite being woven by intangible
threads an atom acquires the magical
property of tangibility
as a result of layers upon layers of
interwoven threads that construct the
fabric that forms its skin
and yet we still have a problem and is
the verb to touch
before a pair of scissors can cut across
it must come in physical contact with
the yarn
tangling is necessarily preceded by
touch
in everyday life we casually say that
the cup touches or is in touch with a
table
have the two objects fuse to form one or
does distance still keep them apart as
distinct objects
for if they fuse to form a single body
it makes little sense to say that they
touched
a verb that requires the participation
of two objects
food for thought
[Music]
you